Let's consider again the situation where we
have a camera looking at an object. Once again
it's a ball. We attach a co-ordinate C to
the camera and we have the co-ordinate of
the ball expressed with respect to the camera
co-ordinate frame.
We're going to introduce a new symbol, which
is F hat, and it is the focal length of a
lens, which is in units of meters, divided
by the dimensions of the pixel given by the
Greek letter Rho. Now Rho has units of meters
per pixel, so the ratio has got units of pixels.
F hat then is another way of representing
the focal length of a lens instead of expressing
it in units of meters, we express it in units of pixels and this can be very useful to us shortly.
We can project the position of the ball into
the image plane, and we represent that by
co-ordinate U, V, there is nothing new in
any of this. I'm going to simplify the notation
and refer to the position of the ball in 3D
space as capital X, capital Y, capital Z and
now we can write the co-ordinates of the projection
of the ball in the image plane in this fashion,
using the symbols X, Y and Z and F hat, which
remember is the focal length of the lens expressed
in units of pixels.
Now let's consider that the camera is moving.
We're going to strap it to a rabbit. The camera
now is able to move with a velocity, which
we can express by a three vector Vx, Vy and
Vz and it's also able to rotate. And we can
express its rotational velocity, as it's angular
velocity with components Omega X, Omega Y
and Omega Z.
Well what happens now? Well we now need to
think about the projection of the ball in
the image plane having not just a location
U, V but it's also got a velocity in the image
plane, which we'll represent by U dot and
V dot.
Now there's a very well known expression that
relates the velocity of the camera to the
pixel velocity in the image plane and these
two quantities are related by a Jacobian matrix
and we have come across Jacobian Matrices
before in the robotics MOOC.
The Jacobian matrix here is a two by six matrix,
which relates the camera velocity and this
is the cameras spatial velocity which has
got a translational component and a rotational
component. Multiplied by this two by six matrix,
to give us the velocity in the image plane.
The velocity at which that point in the image
appears to move.
Here's our MATLAB workspace and we have already
created a camera object. I'm going to compute
the image Jacobian into the workspace variable
J and to do that I am going to use the visjack_p
method, that's short for visual Jacobian for
a point feature, it's a method of the camera
object and I'm going to parse in the co-ordinate
of the image plane point that I'm interested
in and that's at 600, 600, it's got to be
convector, so I put an apostrophe there and
it corresponds to a world point that's five
meters away from the camera.
So here's the visual Jacobian; it is a 2 by
6 matrix. If I multiply the image Jacobian
by a spatial velocity vector, let's consider
a unit velocity in the X direction, no velocity
in Y or Z and no rotation and it's a column
vector, then the image plane point is going
to move at 160 pixels per second in the negative
U direction and it's not going to move at
all in the V direction.
Let's try a different spatial velocity. Let's
look at what happens if it moves in the world
Y direction, we see that it moves at 160 pixels per second in the negative V direction on the image plane.
Let's just look at one more example and we
will move the camera at unit velocity in the
Z direction; that's along the optical axis
and we see that now the image plane point
is moving at 17.6 pixels per second in the U direction and 17.6 pixels per second in the V direction.